as Halloween approaches Media clowns are
out in full costume of hypocritical
outrage accusing everyone else of
ginning up anger how dare you be so
coarse they cry my response crammed at
you jerks let's rewind two months the
Cavanaugh hearings are modern which
trial where we watched a man get
destroyed before his family enabled by a
salivating hateful media blindly
embracing unverified slime packaged by a
well-oiled machine the accusations were
gross nothing close has ever come from
the other side as women in costume
suggested a future where Cavanaugh would
enslave and brutalize women left wing
nuts crashed the hearings outside they
hounded Republicans had died by
Democrats and those defending due
process were branded abuse enablers an
entire party tried to pit gender against
gender remember it's a man in this
country and I just want to say to the
men in this country just shut up and
step up what would you call that
rhetoric divisive heated so now months
later we find that NBC might have sat on
the info that would have discredited
claims of that litigating loon Michael a
vanetti
apparently NBC had the info for weeks
about a witness a vanetti gave to them
who instead of backing Julie sweat
Nick's allegations actually denied them
she also accused a vanetti of twisting
her words surprise yet this news went
nowhere allowing the attacks on the
Cavanaugh's to flourish or what Pelosi
like to call collateral damage and now a
day before Halloween the same blind
self-obsessed media who aided one of the
ugliest spectacles in recent history are
knocking at your door demanding
soul-searching from you and me they pray
you don't remember but we do sorry no
candy for you kids get off our porch
Jessie this story's interesting and it's
not getting a lot of play that NBC
withheld evidence that would have
debunked the this mysterious witness
just kind of went away yeah they don't
want to talk about it because they're
guilty of collusion with the Democratic
Party remember what happened with the
Access Hollywood tape they had Trump on
camera for 10 years saying what he said
and dropped it three weeks before the
general election very suspicious timing
they also spiked the Ronan Farrow expose
Harvey Weinstein because the parent
company had a business relationship with
Weinstein studio and also how about the
cory booker story you know Cory Booker
was credibly accused of forcing
allegedly someone to perform oral sex on
him in a bathroom just recently and the
alleged victim went to Ronan Farrow and
Ronan Farrow didn't touch the story so
I'm wondering why not did it have
anything to do with Cory Booker being a
Democrat and - maybe we should use the
Cavanaugh standard for Booker
I mean guilty until proven innocent and
the media telling you to tone down the
rhetoric I mean that's like an alcoholic
telling you to stop drinking it's like
no you're the drunk you're the drunk you
guys have been saying the president is a
mentally ill racist nazi russian traitor
who needs to be frog-marched out of the
white house calling his daughter the
c-word and hoping his son gets raped and
now you're mad because he calls you fake
news is the enemy of the american people
you guys can dish it out but you can't
take it I think we got some new video
President Trump just arriving at the
University of Pittsburgh Medical Center
right here police officers that are
injured and being treated at the
hospital and and then some additional
people all right so let's go to this
Dana I want to go back to this NBC
claims that this was no longer a story
because by the time this information had
come out he was already the compromising
hearing was over so forget about it so I
read the I read the explanation Kate
snow was the anchor and reporter that
did the interview and so you have to
read the inner you have to read the
explanation like three or four times and
yeah it still doesn't quite make sense
why they wouldn't want to just kind of
own up to it right away yes a we had
this we didn't know they did certainly
jump on it what's interesting is that
how much it just backfired yeah not just
NBC but Bill Hemmer was talking about
there's five key Senate races that we're
gonna watch one of them is Indiana I'm
gonna actually be there tomorrow they
said that the actual momentum for the
Republican the only time you pulled
ahead in the election was after
Kavanaugh mm-hmm why do you think the
Cavanaugh story had in effect or because
when they saw the overreach of the
Democrats on the
the story had a definite attack in terms
of energizing Republican voters the core
the base of the voters that you saw the
spike in terms of their enthusiasm post
cabin on no question about it the
question is whether or not that
enthusiasm has dissipated and whether
people are still reacting what we've
seen I think just in the last week is a
drop in the president's approval ratings
even before the shootings took place so
I think in sense the question is how
much do Republicans still lock into that
moment as a driving force a sense of
grievance that we're leaving let me just
let me just add in terms of the NBC
story the Cates know the reporter stands
by her reporting and I must say I
thought when she interviewed sweat neck
it damaged I don't damage and it damaged
avenatti so I know your perspective Berg
but I'm just saying hey wait a second if
you were on the side of saying hey
there's something new here something
that could be damaging to Cavanaugh
actually it wasn't she said he didn't
spike the punch he did she never saw
anybody lining up outside a door to
assault one I thought it was helpful to
Cavanaugh but the problem is Keith
stones not being honest neither is NBC
they spoke to the second woman at the
end of September the last text message
exchange was October 5th when this woman
said that accused avenatti
of twisting her words and soul to this
day we have no corroborating witnesses
or evidence supporting any of the claims
from Christine for Debra Ramirez or
Julie sweat Nick and it's even more
nefarious than that because you look at
the Washington Post we don't even know
if Emma brown the reporter there ever
had Fords notes
she said she wrote in her column or her
story rather that she received portions
of them but Christine Ford testified
under oath that she wasn't sure she gave
them the note or just a summary of it
and then you go to the New Yorker story
Deborah Mears herself said that she was
very drunk that night she was on the
floor she doesn't remember Ronan Farrow
who is one of the authors said that
Democrats went out seeking Deborah Mears
a story Jane Mayer later would tell Elle
that she that in the me2 area era it is
important to establish a pattern of
behavior that is why they aggressively
pursued this story from Deborah Mears
the New York Times said that they
interviewed several dozen people and
couldn't find a single eyewitness
corroborate the story of Deborah Ramirez
so you have three stories without any
evidence no corroborating witnesses that
yet the media was happy to run these
stories to damage Brett Kavanaugh and it
is wrong that they were they didn't find
anything all right